empörung nach störaktion im bundestag
afd abgeordneten drohen strafrechtliche
konsequenzen
die parteispitze entschuldigt sich
katastrophale corona zustände in den usa
inzwischen sind mehr als 250.000
menschen in verbindung mit dem corona
virus gestorben
neue herausforderungen für deutschen
basketball star dennis schröder wechselt
zum nba champion los angeles lakers
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten auch norbert
könig ist wieder dabei für den sport
sehr gern angenommen
diese vorfälle werden wohl ein nachspiel
haben während sich die aufmerksamkeit
gestern auf die abstimmung über das
infektionsschutzgesetz im parlament und
auf die demonstration davor
konzentrierte fand parallel dazu im
bundestag noch eine andere aktion statt
provokateure waren in das gebäude und
sogar in abgeordneten büros eingedrungen
und hatten versucht politiker
einzuschüchtern
zu den betroffenen gehört auch
wirtschaftsminister altmaier er wurde im
bundestag von einer frau bedrängt
unflätig beschimpft und dabei gefilmt
besucher kommen nur in das
reichstagsgebäude wenn sie über einen
abgeordneten angemeldet sind
es waren politiker der afg fraktion die
die störer und störungen in den
bundestag eingeladen hatten
david gelb hat berichtet es sind szenen
wie diese die empören einschlägig
bekannte rechte aktivisten laufen
gestern über die flure des bundestags
und bedrängen abgeordnete und minister
es folgten beleidigung andere im haus
fühlten sich gar bedroht dass leute sich
in büros einschließen müssen weil sie
angst haben da rede ich jetzt von
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
wir haben offensichtlich den fall
gewesen dass versucht wurde den
abgeordnetenbüros namentlich in denen
des spd-fraktionsvorsitzenden
einzudringen was sind das für zustände
eigentlich durch die sicherheitsschleuse
gelotst von einzelnen parlamentariern
der fdp fraktion waren gäste von zwei
abgeordneten
dabei muss ich allerdings sagen und das
tut mir sehr leid dass zwei der gäste
sich der kontrolle durch die einladen
entzogen haben und dabei sind dinge
vorgefallen die ich zutiefst bedauert
doch teile der fdp fraktion arbeiten
seit langem eng mit solchen aktivisten
zusammen aus kalkül rechte youtuber
haben das ziel prominente politiker
vorzuführen sie in eine situation der
peinlichkeit zu bringen sich in eine
rechtfertigung situation zu bringen
letztlich dient das der delegitimation
parlamentarischer verfahrensabläufe am
mittag lag der sogenannte ältestenrat
des bundestags dem vertreter aller
parteien angehören alle außer der afg
sind sie später einig es muss
konsequenzen geben
§ 106 strafgesetzbuch nötigung von mir
aus könnte einschlägig sein
das werden wir sehr sorgfältig prüfen
aber es wird tatsächlich auch
konsequenzen geben müssen denn wir
müssen aufpassen dass nicht im
bundestagswahljahr der reis sagt zur
bühne für solche show einlagen der ard
buffet in der vergangenheit morgen soll
es auch im plenum eine aktuelle stunde
geben die aufarbeitung fängt erst an
es ist also von strafrechtlichen
konsequenzen die räder konnten banerjee
was macht diesen fall aber politisch so
brisant
es geht hier um einen tabubruch das wäre
jetzt war der afg nicht so erstaunlich
denn der tabubruch gehörte
erklärtermaßen zum markenkern dieser
partei
allerdings hat sie in diesem fall eine
für die demokratie symbolträchtige
grenze überschritten
im bundestag herrscht zum einen protest
verbot und es gibt eben auch ein verbot
abgeordnete unter druck zu setzen ganz
besonders vor abstimmungen und zu mal
vor einer so wichtigen abstimmung wie
gestern
letzteres steht sogar unter strafe wäre
also möglicherweise ein straftatbestand
und umso brisanter ist es dass die störe
um die ist da geht sich nicht
eigenmächtig zutritt verschafft haben
zum bundestag sondern eingeladen worden
sind von afd abgeordneten
das erklärt auch die geschlossene
haltung aller anderen fraktionen die
jetzt angekündigt haben wirklich jedes
rechtliche mittel zu prüfen und wir
können auch davon ausgehen dass das was
an sanktionen möglich ist unter anderem
auch gegen die afg abgeordneten
wahrscheinlich dann noch angewendet wird
vielen dank für die informationen schack
unterlag
weitere hintergründe zu der störaktion
im bundestag gibt es um halb acht in zdf
heute live zu sehen auf zdf heute.de und
in der app mehrmals erhielt die afd
dubiose gelder aus der schweiz
jetzt muss sie deshalb eine halbe
million strafe zahlen
das entschied die bundestagsverwaltung
in einem fall handelt es sich um
verschleierte spenden an den
kreisverband von fraktions chefin alice
weide im anderen geht es um die
finanzierung eines afd kongresses auch
hier ist unklar wer genau hinter den
geldzuwendungen steckt mehr als zwei
wochen gelten jetzt die verschärften
chor ohne regeln aber auch heute keine
entwarnung vom robert-koch-institut das
lka meldete 22 1609 neuinfektionen das
sind gut 700 mehr als vergangenen
donnerstag 251 menschen sind binnen 24
stunden in verbindung mit dem virus
gestorben
fast überall in deutschland sind die
fallzahlen noch immer besorgniserregend
hoch zum beispiel im
rheinland-pfälzischen speyer von rattle
check speyer ist seit tagen
spitzenreiter in der domstadt hört das
aber keiner gerne denn speyer für die
korona liste in rheinland pfalz an
umgerechnet 235 vier menschen pro
100.000 einwohner sind in einer woche am
virus erkrankt die stadtverwaltung
rätselt bei der ursachenforschung seit
gestern gilt in teilen der innenstadt
einem mundschutz pflicht da müssen wir
durch und speyer das berchtesgadener
land oder auch herne in
nordrhein-westfalen es gibt immer wieder
neue hotspots und das bereitet dem
robert-koch-institut sorgen
dessen chef betont auch heute wieder die
lage sei sehr ernst wir sind noch lange
nicht über den berg die fallzahlen haben
sich stabilisiert wir wissen aber nicht
ob das schon eine trendwende ist durch
die hohen fallzahlen ist es möglich dass
manche kliniken an ihre grenzen kommen
es ist möglich dass patienten nicht mehr
überall optimal versorgt werden können
die zahl der schweren erkrankungen an
und mit kurven 19 nimmt zu fast
automatisch steigt damit auch die zahl
der toten die experten beim
robert-koch-institut müssen eine bittere
statistik führen wurden uns 267
todesfälle innerhalb eines tages
übermittelt für dienstag 305 und für den
gestrigen tag also mit stand heute 0 uhr
251 todesfälle
es kann also sein dass diese woche
insgesamt über 1000 todesfälle berichtet
werden bekennende masken muffel offenbar
viele menschen im landkreis bautzen hier
in sachsen stieg die zahl der
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner auf
jetzt 3 179,6 das ist der höchste wert
in deutschland in die usa dort ist die
dynamik der korona krise noch
ungebrochen seit beginn der pandemie
sind mehr als eine viertelmillion
menschen an oder mit dem virus gestorben
und auch die gemeldeten täglichen
neuinfektion erreichen immer wieder neue
höchstwerte und lagen zuletzt bei rund
170000 mrt wissen berichtet rating
gonzález ist zu jung um das zu begreifen
was sein leben für immer verändert im
juni verlor der vierjährige seinen vater
reden und cupid im oktober seine mutter
maria im ganzen land spüren menschen den
verlust von familienmitgliedern und
freunden eine viertel million tote
wieder fehlt es an intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte das leid trifft den
künftigen präsidenten der sich bei
helfern über die dramatische lage
informiert die regierung kümmert sich
nicht deshalb verschärft sich die
pandemie auf die helfer werden krank und
sterben
63 trotzdem mutter sagt donald trump
offenbar jede kommunikation mit den
beiden team- und verbreitet per twitter
lieber weiter die lüge von angeblicher
wahlfälschung gegen korona schloss der
größte schulbezirk des landes new york
city heute wieder alle schulen
vielerorts müssen bars und restaurants
dicht machen eine masken pflicht lehnen
einige republikanische gouverneure
weiter immer häufiger berichten pfleger
von schwerkranken patienten die unbeirrt
die existenz der krankheit leugnen an
der sie vielleicht sogar sterben werden
ihre letzten bach der sind das kann
nicht passieren das ist nicht erst statt
noch einmal mit ihren familien zu reden
sie erfüllt von wut und hass und das
macht mich traurig es wirkt ein
trauriges giving fans nächste woche im
allerkleinsten familienkreis oder am
besten gar nicht viele amerikaner lassen
sich vorher noch testen und die zahl der
positiv fälle steigt weiter rasant
ein veto aus ungarn und polen hat die eu
in eine handfeste politische krise
gestürzt
zur stunde suchen europas staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen auf einem
virtuellen gipfel nach einem ausweg
worum geht es um den 1,8 billionen euro
schweren eu haushalt für die kommenden
sieben jahre und die darin enthaltenen
corona hilfen von 750 milliarden euro
ungarn und polen blockieren dieses
finanzpaket sie wollen verhindern dass
die eu ihnen künftig gelder kürzen kann
beispielsweise weil sie die
unabhängigkeit der justiz missachten
ja das sieht nach einer ganz verfahrenen
situation aus anne gellinek in brüssel
ist denn überhaupt eine lösung denkbar
tatsächlich haben die staats- und
regierungschefs das thema zu beginn
ihrer video-konferenz nur kurz gestreift
denn die fronten sind so verhärtet dass
man hier erst mal nicht weiterkommt
viktor orban verglich die eu mit der
sowjetunion vor der konferenz und in
polen beschimpfte man die
rechtsstaatlichkeit klausel als deutsche
willkür maßnahme aus brüssel
ihnen gegenüber sitzen 25
regierungschefs die wenig lust verspüren
den haushaltskompromiss und den zur
rechtsstaatlichkeit noch einmal
aufzuschnüren und deshalb denkt man hier
in brüssel laut und demonstrativ über
eine lösung ohne polen und ungarn nach
zumindest was den dringend benötigten
corona hilfsfonds anbetrifft
man könnte sich vorstellen dass ein klub
der 25 willigen regierungen gemeinsam
schulden aufnimmt und die gelder dann
verteilt holen und ungarn wären dann
außen vor
das ist vielleicht nicht mehr als eine
drohkulisse weil auch hier die gelder
nicht schnell fließen könnten
aber es zeigt wie tief die krise ist und
das mit harten bandagen gekämpft wird
die deutsche rats präsidentschaft und
die mehrheit der staats und
regierungschefs will sich nicht von
polen und ungarn erpressen lassen wo der
ausweg liegt allerdings ist völlig offen
vielen dank an agennix nach brüssel
kriegsverbrechen begangen von
australischen elite soldaten in
afghanistan
was bisher vorwürfe waren ist jetzt
aktenkundig in einem
untersuchungsbericht ist die rede von
einer beschämenden bilanz von einer
egozentrischen krieger kultur und vor
allem von schwersten verstößen 25
elitesoldaten sollen zivilisten und
gefangene in afghanistan misshandelt und
getötet haben normen odenthal mit
einzelheiten was australiens höchster
militär vorliegt ist ein offenbarungseid
der bericht über kriegsverbrechen
begangen von australischen soldaten in
afghanistan zu den schändlichen taten
zählen aufnahmerituale für neue
gruppenmitglieder ihre opfer waren
gefangene bauern zivilisten
vorgesetzte hielten neue soldaten an
gefangenen zu erschießen das erste mal
töten ein entsetzlicher ritus genannt
platin blut taufe könnte man zu
übersetzen nichts jedenfalls was im
gefecht geschieht auch kehlen sollen
durchschnitten worden sein
39 todesopfer führt der bericht auf
beschuldigt 25 soldaten angehörige einer
spezialeinheit zwischen 2005 und 2016
der bericht zeigt dass diese unkultur
von erfahrenen charismatischen unter
offizieren auf ihre untergebenen
übertragen wurde
sie haben militärische werte mit krieger
kult egoismus und elitedenken vermischt
zeugen in afghanistan berichten von
weiteren gräueln doch der untersuchung
zufolge müssen sie sich wohl noch
glücklich schätzen überlebt zu haben
ich wurde im gefängnis gefoltert sie
beschuldigten mich den taliban zu helfen
sie ließen mich nicht schlafen damit die
augen zufielen tragen ein soldat gegen
den kopf ein australischer
sonderermittler soll nun klären ob
strafrechtlich gegen die soldaten
vorgegangen werden kann das wird dauern
von der militärführung gab es heute
immerhin schon ein klares wort
entschuldigung
rund 100 kilometer stasi akten sind
archiviert und ein zeugnis der
sed-diktatur für dieses stück geschichte
ist künftig nicht mehr die stasi
unterlagen behörde zuständig sondern das
bundesarchiv das hat das parlament heute
beschlossen
auch das amt an der spitze der behörde
wird aufgelöst
die akten aber bleiben weiterhin
zugänglich künftig auch digital und an
weiteren standorten die aufarbeitung des
wettskandals im parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss nimmt heute erst
richtig fahrt auf
direkt aus der untersuchungshaft
persönlich erscheinen musste ex
vorstandschef markus braun
er hatte jahrelang beste kontakte in die
politik
und so stellt sich die frage gab es
versäumnisse der bundesregierung und der
aufsichtsbehörden der
finanzdienstleister wirecard hatte
jahrelang bilanzen gefälscht gläubiger
und gläubiger rinnen haben forderungen
in höhe von 12,4 milliarden euro
angemeldet
versteckt in der tiefgarage des
bundestages steht er diesen mittag die
fahrzeugkolonne die markus braun aus der
untersuchungshaft in augsburg nach
berlin brachte der ehemalige wirecard
chef hat alles versucht um nicht selbst
vor dem untersuchungsausschuss
erscheinen zu müssen
er rief dafür sogar den
bundesgerichtshof an und verlor vor dem
ausschuss ließ brown eine erklärung ab
fragen zu seiner verantwortung
beantwortete er nicht
ich habe heute die lebendigste mumie
erlebt der ich in meinem leben begegnet
bin und ich kann gut verstehen
auch die wut die sicherlich viele
menschen spüren die zum beispiel ihre
lebensersparnisse verloren haben gegen
brown ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft
wegen gewerbsmäßigen bandenbetrugs es
geht unter anderem um 1,9 milliarden
euro die verschwunden sind
der untersuchungsausschuss soll klären
ob bundesregierung und behörden bei der
kontrolle von wirecard versagt haben
wichtig dabei ein treffen von
finanzstaatssekretär cookies mit brown
vor einem jahr
der zeitpunkt wo es krasse vorwürfe
gegen wirecard gab wo ja auch schon ein
sondergutachten den auftrag gegeben war
dass ich dann ein staatssekretär beim
dax i einlädt um offenbar ja nach diesen
in die 10 uhr über dieses thema zu
sprechen das macht uns schon sehr
misstrauisch gemeint ist eine mail aus
dem spd geführten finanzministerium zur
vorbereitung des treffens mit brown die
dem zdf vorliegt einziges thema mögliche
kursmanipulation um wirecard nichts
neues aus sicht der spd
insofern verstehe ich dass das ein
relevanter ein relevantes treffen war
das da transparenz hergestellt werden
muss
ich frage aber wo ist eigentlich die
neuigkeit brown sagte er wolle morgen
erstmals vor der staatsanwaltschaft
aussagen
gut möglich dass er dann auch bald
wieder
nach berlin fahren muss die korona krise
macht dem ohnehin angeschlagenen
traditionskonzern thyssenkrupp schwer zu
schaffen
noch mehr stellen als bisher geplant
werden gestrichen
statt 6000 sind es nun 11.000
arbeitsplätze kündigungen werden
ausdrücklich nicht ausgeschlossen
vor allem die stahlsparte und das
automobilgeschäft leiden so der vorstand
weltweit arbeiten rund 100000 menschen
bei dem konzern
ja und damit sind wir schon beim sport
und einem spektakulären vereinswechsel
im basketball und zwar in der weltbesten
liga nba
dennis schröder macht den nächsten
karriereschritt der vorzeitige wechsel
des deutschen nationalspielers von
oklahoma city thunder zum meister los
angeles lakers ist perfekt ein
volltreffer in der nba deutschlands
beste basketballspieler dennis schröder
nun also bei den los angeles lakers den
aktuellen champions deren superstar
lebron james dennis schröder schon per
instagram willkommen heißt
bei oklahoma city thunder zur festen
größe gereift fühlte sich dort wohl nun
im tausch gegen lakers akteur danny
green star ensemble nach los angeles
transferiert muss schröder sich dort
behaupten der bundestrainer sieht darin
eine chance glaube dass er insgesamt als
spieler als persönlichkeit sehr
gewachsen ist und sicherlich den beckers
helfen kann
vielleicht kann der kleine aufbauspieler
dennis schröder ja dort ein ganz großer
champion werden
champions sind sie nicht geworden aber
theresa stoll und katharina mänz freuen
sich trotzdem sie haben in ihrer
jeweiligen gewichtsklasse bronze
gewonnen bei den
judo-europameisterschaften in prag
mehr als acht monate sind seitdem saison
abbruch in der deutschen eishockey liga
vergangen nun ist die entscheidung
gefallen kurz vor weihnachten soll es
wieder losgehen mit allen 14 teams und
neuem modus die lehre eisfläche ist bald
geschichte ist erstmal eine
riesen-erleichterung glaube ich für alle
dass es weitergeht dass eine perspektive
da ist es war eine unglaubliche
kraftanstrengung
die neuerungen die 14 teams werden
aufgeteilt in gruppen nord und gruppe
süd so wird im sinne der korona
maßnahmen weniger gereist und man spart
kosten
in der hauptrunde gibt es mehr spiele
innerhalb der eigenen gruppe als
überregionale begegnungen
so wird die gesamtzahl der spiele
reduziert wichtig bei der stark
verkürzten saison playoffs wird es auch
diesmal geben für das finale gilt der
modus best of three zwei siege genügend
zur meisterschaft mit zuschauern wird
vorerst nicht geplant
finanziert wird die saison unter anderem
durch staatliche hilfen und
gehaltsverzicht von spielern und
trainern
startschuss ist er siebzehnter dezember
da heißt es endlich wieder raus aufs eis
doch was muss man ja danke norbert
bislang war der november eher mild aber
das ändert sich gerade es wird kälter
und damit steigt zumindest im süden die
glättegefahr
einzelheiten gleich von katja honnefer
so viel von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren
mehr gibt es im heute journal mit
christian sievers um 21 uhr 45 und uns
gibt es morgen wieder um 19 uhr einen
entspannten abend wünschen wird
[Musik]
meine damen und herren tief roswitha
macht uns heute gleich zwei kaltfronten
die erste kaltfront brachte den regen
die zweite dann den strom und die
deutlich tieferen temperaturen
diese kalte luft können sie sehr schön
erkennen an dieser streuselkuchen
artigen bewölkung darunter verbergen
sich kräftige schauer und die begleiten
uns an der nordsee auch durch die nacht
sonst ist es häufig klar südlich der
mosel ist es allerdings auch mal stärker
bewölkt da kann es noch einige schauer
geben und an den alpen fällt schnee
schnee regen die schneefallgrenze liegt
ungefähr bei 800 meter da kann es also
glatt sein genauso wie auch in den
mittelgebirgen für glätte reich ist aber
in deutschland fast überall denn bei
temperaturen zwischen plus 3 und minus
zwei grad droht überall bodenfrost und
ausgenommen davon sind einzig rügen die
ostfriesischen inseln und der oberrhein
nach dieser wirklich sehr kalt nachts
bleibt es dann auch tagsüber frisch mit
einstelligen 2 bis 8 grad
morgen gibt es im nordwesten noch einige
schauer und dem harz kann auch noch mal
ein bisschen schnee dabei sein freund
hier sieht es im osten aus und vor allen
dingen auch in süddeutschland im
erzgebirge gibt es noch einige
schneeregenschauer genauso wie er in den
alpen die lassen aber im laufe des tages
mehr und mehr nach und am wochenende
beschränken sich die regenfälle meist
auf norddeutschland es bleibt kühl bei
drei bis elf grad schön aber noch